Ukraine says more than 100 civilians
were evacuated from the besieged as of
style steel plant in mariu pole on
Sunday the plant is the last part of the
city not occupied by Russian forces
hundreds more people are still trapped
there along with around 2 000 Ukrainian
soldiers evacuations were carried in
coordination with United Nations and Red
Cross after talks to open a humanitarian
corridor
rescued from the rubble the civilian
survivors of the as of style steel plant
climbed from the darkness of bunkers
under the cover of a two-day ceasefire
video released by The as of regiment
show the final steps of an almost
unbearable weight for help
we've been here for two months
her baby turns six months old a day
earlier a young life spent under siege
these children tell how they almost ran
out of food
the children wanted to eat all the time
you know adults can endure the
evacuations were the result of tireless
diplomacy praised by Ukrainian president
of Vladimir zielinsky
after many weeks of negotiations after
many attempts different meetings people
calls countries proposals finally there
was not a single day when we did not try
to find a solution that would save our
people
Russia's military also released its
video of people being transported from
as of style and taken to camps it says
those wishing to be evacuated to
ukrainian-held territory will be passed
over to the United Nations and Red Cross
the survivor's best stories of existing
in squalid conditions in oxygen-deprived
bunkers
I can't believe it
two months of darkness when we were in
the bus I told my husband we won't have
to use a flashlight to go to the toilet
in a bag and Bin we didn't see any
sunlight we were scared we foreign
and Red Cross hope to help more
civilians out of mariupole hundreds
still remain in as of style
waiting for a similar Escape
is standing by for us in key fenney it's
good to see you around 100 civilians
were able to leave that as of style on
Sunday what are the plans to get the
rest of them out
definitely there's a call on making sure
more and more people get out in fact
behind me you see this Banner that says
in Ukrainian Mario Paul which translates
in English to d block Mario Paul now
that city is unlikely to be liberated at
this point because it's controlled by
Russia for the most part except for that
steel plant where hundreds of people
remain trapped but those 100 civilians
that could leave the steel plant
yesterday and really we are speaking
about children who see sunlight again
for the first time in weeks who actually
get some fresh water and and basic
things more people would like to enjoy
at this a freedom again but will they
that's the question now the city council
of maripole said that in fact a bigger
evacuation is due to start this morning
but it was already delayed from
yesterday also reports that shelling
resumed after this first group of people
left the steel plant as a result really
the question is will this evacuation
continue Mary Paul how many more people
are going to leave certainly the people
who are inside would like to get out not
only civilians but also wounded soldiers
and let's not forget unfortunately
according to information inside they're
also that body is that are decomposing
it's really harrowing just imagine that
alone experience what people are going
through inside the steel plant as we are
speaking we mentioned them there those
soldiers what's the plan to evacuate
them are they part of this plan funny
the deputy commander of the as of
regiment made clear that they want
everyone out there both civilians and
soldiers but at the same time this
Deputy Commander ultimately had they not
been inside to defend the steel plant
and then the entire Frontline actually
of Russia would be even further up
towards the north so he's basically also
justifying in a way already that it was
very important and it is important to
defend the steel plant to make sure to
prevent that Russia advances even
further which is obviously stands in in
in the line of what the Russian plan is
to advance especially in the donbass
region but also in the southern part of
Ukraine whether more people are going to
get out we are not only speaking about 1
000 civilians inside that's the estimate
but about 2 000 soldiers who are also
inside or underneath this steel plant
you have to imagine this is like a
system of various bunkers partly child
partly with mines it's very difficult to
get people out out and the next day I'll
just have to see and prove whether
that's going to be possible and a
ceasefire can be maintained to help
people out from the steel plant in Mario
pool funny thanks very much for that
update DW correspondent Fanning fascia
and keys
well for more I'm joined by Frank
ledwich he's a senior lecturer in
strategy and law at the University of
Portsmouth and a former military
intelligence officer Frank thanks very
much to speaking for speaking to us this
morning so some hundred civilians have
been evacuated that does give some hope
tell us why haven't Russian troops been
able to take that steel plant do you
think
as first of all it's extremely difficult
to take any built up area you need the
rules say essentially you need a five to
one preponderance of forces in built up
areas and something like the steel plant
is absolutely vicious again for
attackers this reminds historians owning
almost anyone who knows any about
military history very much of the
tractor Factory at Stalingrad which the
Russians held on to it's iconic in
Russian military history they held on to
it for three months and it's it's very
possible to happen here but also Russian
difficulties compounded by the fact that
during the Cold War the as of style
complex was was treated as one of the
sort of cores of the cause as in the
centers of the nuclear defense system so
it's filled with underground bunkers
it'd be really difficult to clear those
out so it's a really difficult nut to
crack for Russians elsewhere the Russian
troops have made minor advances
particularly in the Don bass but on the
other hand ukrainians Ukrainian soldiers
have managed to push back in some areas
particularly taking back some key
villages in the khakive region and these
front lines seem to be barely moving are
we in the midst of a war of attrition
very much so this is a grinding more of
artillery of small movements of maneuver
Warfare and the ukrainians are far
better than that than the Russians at
that than the Russians interestingly in
the north there you mentioned kharkiv
the the problem for the Russians there
is the Ukraine is getting quite close to
being able to Shell some of the Russian
supply routes to the South so some
analysts are looking at this and saying
well this this may result in the
Russians actually withdrawing forces
from the donbass area north to try and
defend that but we'll see see that
what's happening in the South have is
very interesting reports indicate that
yesterday the Russian chief of the
general staff General grassimov has
almost caught in an artillery strike
which killed dozens of officers and he
was there evidently to see what's
holding all this up and of course what's
holding it up is the endemic ramshackle
nature of the Russian army it's simply
not up to Modern standards but that's a
set of issues they're making very slow
progress Rebecca all right Frank
unfortunately we're gonna have to leave
it there Frank ledwich for a former
military intelligence offer thanks very
much for your time
thanks Rebecca
well more than 5 million ukrainians have
now fled their country since the War
Began according to the United Nations
the vast majority of them are women and
children in the western Ukrainian city
of Lev The Exodus means some schools are
virtually empty one of them is using its
empty classrooms to provide shelter to
refugees from other parts of the country
since the war started Ivan lazensko's
Ukrainian German School in neviv has
drastically changed although we meet him
on a weekday there is no child inside
of course the school has changed a lot
because 43 percent of the children now
live abroad
they still actively take part in remote
learning classes
the school's premises didn't remain
empty for long with the help of parents
and volunteers Yvonne decided to host
internally displaced people from the
regions worst affected by the war so far
almost 200 people have stayed here
mostly men as they are not allowed to
leave the country
Vladimir arrived to the school at the
end of March he fled from demudif near
Kiev carrying only a few belongings and
this paper was him where he wrote down
that after a stroke he couldn't talk
very fast and needed immediate
evacuation
we just walked there was a 50-50 chance
to end up dead or alive we walked
through
we walked past the dam
on the road to the bridge which was
blown up by our army
I passed the first Russian checkpoint
without problems
but on the second I was stopped and they
asked me what do you have here
when I said my cell phone it was taken
away
through us
because
Vladimir sleeps in what used to be the
school's main hall now transformed into
a dormitory
there we also meet Alexandra who hopes
to join the Ukraine and Armed Forces
I came alone my family stayed near
Harkins we live in the northern part
closer to Russia and it's been bombed
every day since the beginning of the war
nearly everyone in the neighborhood left
town
I still have to pass a medical check to
join the Army and after that I don't
know I don't have a military specialty
so I'll probably have to train for a few
months
in what used to be classrooms we meet
mikhailo and his son-in-law Dennis from
butcher their wives now live in Germany
they have lost all of their possessions
and only brought Mickey the family dog
on the evening of February 28th Russian
soldiers knocked on Denny's door
Russian troops fought to be removed me
from a flat and came with rifles they
searched me broke my mobile phones and
stole my laptops they brought me to the
nearby church and told me not to come
outside until sunrise they set up their
military position and their artillery
there's only me and two other men in the
morning we left and settled here
[Music]
in his school Ivan provides some relief
to fellow ukrainians who have lost
everything but those displaced people
and especially men are left in limbo
here in Nevada not knowing if and when
they will be able to return home
like in Ukraine war has separated
families across the country some have
fled war-torn areas leaving others
behind to fight DW has been speaking to
a woman in Western Ukraine who received
a very special video message from her
boyfriend fighting on the front line
I can rely on you in difficult times I
love you very much I don't have a
wedding ring for you right now but I do
have a ring on this grenade I would love
you to be my wife please marry me
was hoping for a sign of life from her
boyfriend when she looked at her phone
three weeks ago then she saw the video
that would change her life forever
I wanted to say yes instantly I tried to
text him or call but I couldn't get
through then he finally called back and
I said how could I refuse you especially
with a grenade in your hand
after the War Began Anastasia fled to
the city of leviv her boyfriend went to
fight in the donbass region one of the
most dangerous War zones sometimes he
sends her little videos and of the photo
he always carries in his first aid bag
but Anastasia hasn't heard from him for
days
there are moments when I can't take it
anymore and I start crying I try to make
sure no one sees me I don't want anyone
to feel sorry for me
oh I know is if something happens to him
oh God
according to martial law ukrainians can
even get married remotely but in
Anastasia's case that's not an option
he is in a very difficult place
there's no internet no pens not even
paper
he can't even wash himself properly
Anastasia says at some point the war
will end then they will get married
properly and she will no longer have to
walk alone